[Música]
muchas personas te dicen no te preocupes
tranquilo no pasa nada como si la
preocupación fuera un síntoma de
ansiedad o de estrés y esa es una mala
concepción de la preocupación la
preocupación es un gran mecanismo del
cual disponemos los humanos tampoco es
un mecanismo que sirva para solucionar
problemas no como mi amigo jacinto que
jacinto tenía mucho miedo de volar
siempre tenía que tomar el avión y un
día me dice sabes qué y ha encontrado la
solución es así como difumina el otro
día tomé un avión pero antes de tomar el
avión me puse con un calcetín rojo y un
calcetín azul y ya tengo la solución
madre mía
digo unas cosas que les sirva para
regular su ansiedad no a modo de
superstición pero obviamente no es la
solución
también el hecho de que algo una acción
falle como por ejemplo si alguien
fallece en un accidente automovilístico
y lleva el cinturón de seguridad puesto
eso no quiere decir que no sea una
acción preventiva muy eficaz pero a
veces fallo
la propuesta que les presento aquí es
viene derivada del modelo pan está el
modelo pan está de preocupación que
explica cómo funciona la preocupación y
panta viene de sus acrónimos la p es
percepción de una posible amenaza futura
de activación o de arousal la m de
motivación la t de pensar en inglés y la
de actuación o ocupación
y según el modelo pampa la preocupación
es un mecanismo complejo evolucionado
del miedo cómo funciona el miedo y el
miedo cuando percibimos una amenaza
inminente y que corremos gran peligro
nos va la vida por ejemplo entonces se
activa el organismo el corazón empieza a
latir fuerte y va la sangre a los brazos
y a las piernas para que para huir o
luchar estamos en las mejores
condiciones posibles
y ello lo que regula el sistema
simpático tenemos dos sistemas
básicamente recuerdos para el sistema
nervioso autónomo que es el simpático y
parasimpático el parasimpático regula
funciones como la digestión la
relajación el sueño la fase rem y en la
respuesta sexual la erección en el
momento en que tenemos una erección los
varones necesitamos mucha sangre pero
una gran cantidad de sangre para que el
pene que directo mucha sangre
ahí siempre alguien de idea no será
tanta y digo habla por ti
en mi caso tengo un pene grande
le tengo mucho cariño
de hecho yo le llamo smith
hablamos platicamos
y a veces fantasía si tuviera dos penes
así como los tiburones al otro le
pondría huesos así sería smith and
wesson porque calzón 38
bueno el caso es que si estamos teniendo
relaciones sexuales con una señora
no se pongan contentos entonces
en ese momento aparece un señor por la
puerta con cara seria mejor dicho cara
enfadado
como si fuera el marido la señora con el
que un oscar
y como un hacha la elección de un
segundo pasa así
en mi caso del 38 al 22
y eso porque se activa el sistema
simpático siempre salta una idea
trillo no se proclame el simpático
millón el libro la gracia
y yo tampoco le veo
pero es muy efectivo porque la sangre
que estaba en el pene toda esa sangre va
a los brazos y a las piernas y estamos
en las mejores condiciones de huir o
luchar y es muy efectivo de hecho a mi
amigo jacinto pues estaba en esta
situación se asustó brincó por el saldo
por el edificio saltó tres pisos y no se
hizo nada bajó corriendo por la calle y
con que era sin moreno o playa se veía
un culo blanco un culo blanco lo lejos y
eso sí un calcetín rojo y otro azul
que me da mucha suerte siempre lo lleva
obviamente lo que le sirvió es la
respuesta digamos del sistema simpático
pero ahora impóngase ostiense en la
sabana en la sabana hay muchos animales
cebras new es antílopes impalas el
fokker o heces de jabalí con los cuerpos
de el jabalí verrugoso la suricata la
cazuela de thomson que uno piensa si eso
se ve en la sabana no te digo lo que hay
debajo del colchón
[Aplausos]
el caso es que hay una cebra o una
gacela thompson y percibe un depredador
entonces se le activa el sistema
simpático al corazón empieza a latir va
la sangre a las extremidades y empieza a
correr si han visto documentales lo
reconocerán suele ir en cámara lenta
la cebra
y luego va la leona de atrás suelen ser
ellas
y la cebra está dando patadas
[Aplausos]
en un 90% de los casos la cebra se libra
de tal manera que es un gran mecanismo
que tenemos todos los mamíferos el del
miedo
pero en la sabana prácticamente todos si
no todos los mamíferos tienen sistemas
perspectiva son mucho más agudos que los
humanos en olfato vista oído de tal
manera que perciben a los a los
potenciales depredadores mucho antes de
nosotros y a nivel de locomoción también
son mucho más eficaces corren todos
mucho más mucho más que nosotros es que
es el jamaicano
no manches mancha
solo funcionáramos con el miedo los
humanos ya no estaríamos en la faz de la
tierra
con la evolución se nos hipertrofia en
el lóbulo frontal y se desarrolló el
lenguaje y somos capaces de anticiparnos
podemos como dice el modelo panta
percibir una posible amenaza futura sin
verla y oírla
entonces se activa en menor medida el
sistema simpático nos activamos y
estamos motivados para pensar y hacer
acciones que nos van a van a reducir la
probabilidad que aparezca esa amenaza en
caso de que aparezca paliar sus efectos
de hecho en la sabana los masai pues
salientes tienen temen de que pueda
haber algún león otro depredador y
entonces optan por ir con escudos y
lanzas
entonces van en grupo y van cantando y
eso disuade a bastantes depredadores y
en caso de aparecer están en las mejores
condiciones posibles para hacerle frente
tan maneras los humanos por ejemplo
somos capaces de pensar que tendremos
futuras enfermedades y comprar un seguro
de enfermedades
el día que una cebra o una gacela
thompson compre un seguro de
enfermedades ese día cambiaremos la
teoría
de tal manera es verdad que la
preocupación puede fallar por muchos
lados como señala un modelo pampa pero
es un gran mecanismo y yo les recomiendo
que se preocupen pero preocúpese bien yo
antes de empezar esta charla estaba
preocupado pero para qué sé yo tengo
miedo de que no se entienda de que no
guste entonces no me altera un poquito y
me preparé dice un guión no fue
modificando luego hice unos ensayos
tal digo a ver si me sale bien y al
final pues hasta me puse un calcetín de
cada color
espero que les haya gustado muchas
gracias